[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va jouer vous allez jouer tous
contrefaçon d'accord bon alors premier
jeu il y avait plein de gens dans le
bigdil bill est ce que tu peux nous
expliquer le premier jeu ces passants
qui va animer poids des ans on a mis
série mon ami vincent le premier jeu
s'appelle la montagne de sucre ap
le but du jeu est d'empiler sur un seul
morceau de sucre le plus de sucre
possible attention vous ne pouvez pas
jouer si vous êtes allé ensuite au
gluten
[Musique]
tu peux poser kaiser comme tu veux et le
big deal il faisait 11 millions de
téléspectateurs j'adore pour l'instant
ça mais on a la pression mais c'est pas
là les trop vite
vous connaissez bien valérie et vincent
ouais ouais on a un peu bricolé sur une
chaîne m6 et ouais ouais ouais la
perceuse c'est à toi je sais plus quelle
émission où on avait fait on avait fait
la millième on a eu pas mal de choses ça
peut durer un à l'ehess
je vais rajouter un autre cadeau parce
que comme c'est très long je vais
rajouter en plus si tu gagnes tu as dit
ben ali al-hadi vincent on rajoute une
machine à café steegen à à elle est là
elle est bien allé à la plage on est là
qui va gagner autrement dit comme on
l'entend dans le speed mouchoirs jong il
on dirait pas comme ça mais c'est très
dur de vider une boîte de mouchoirs en
papier le premier qui arrive gagner le
jeu attention vous ne pouvez utiliser
qu'une seule manche oui on doit on doit
avec une salle on doit on doit
impérativement enlevez vos choix un
parent et tu peux préparer le premier
wpt deux étapes
mais une baisse olala aller travailler
très fort parce qu'elle a tellement
pleuré
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais les locaux tenaient d'ailleurs
d'extrémisme
s'il bat benjamin et géraldine ya un
truc s'était jamais vu un aussi bon dans
les bons dans cette émission du jeu est
de former entre deux personnes la plus
longue file de cadettes
on assume les canettes une par une les
premiers qu'ils font tomber leurs
canettes sont éliminés il est un gars
comme al aqsa les premiers qui fait
tomber les canettes les prairies
accompli alors le jeu les caennais ne
sais pas avec qui rejouent va qui a fait
alors le but du jeu il est très simple
on se met face à face dans nos équipes
ont mis une première canette commencé et
fini de sièges
attention je le promets qu'il fait
tomber laquelle elle n'a perdu la junte
alors on joue avec des canettes vides à
l'époque
ah oui bah oui on joue avec des canapés
ces passeurs qui avance avec des
canettes vides mais paris c'est comme ça
quoique c'est bien on ne bouge pas en
fait faut que j'en ai un qui bouge pas
et l'autre rouge
je sors gobain attend on et comment là
on est comme moi t'es pas bien c'est pas
bien eh bien non ah oui on est bien loin
pour l'instant au début mais recule
pense pas pour l'instant du mal tu
bouges et oui oui d'accord ok mais ne
l'a pas ratée pas bien lâché moi ça
s'appelle un métier n'attaquez pas bon
sens mais on est bien ailleurs les palio
la même temps benjamin normalement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]